hey what's up guys and welcome to
something a little different as you can
probably tell this is dark souls modded
and it's going to be the first in a
three-part series where i'm going to mod
the game in some of my favorite ways and
basically showcase it to you so it's
pretty obvious what i've modded in this
video we're playing in first person and
you're watching me fight through the
first stage in order to reach the taurus
demon and playing like this was actually
a lot of fun obviously it's not perfect
there are some camera bugs but it's
definitely functional as you'll see i
don't have too much trouble making my
way through the stage one of the best
things i've actually done is pick up
this spear and this was a good choice
for a few reasons one it's highly
visible in first person and two rolling
actually messes with the camera so you
tend to use your shield a lot and in any
situation where you use your shield the
spear is just naturally a good choice
so what's it like playing in first
person well you'll get some idea as you
watch these gameplay clips but if i had
to describe it to someone else basically
it's like skyrim but with gameplay the
combat works surprisingly well but i'd
only really recommend it to an
experienced player who knows weapon move
sets enemy patterns and someone who has
a really good grasp of the controls and
the reason i say this is that it's not
perfect the camera has trouble adjusting
sometimes and if you know exactly how to
move your character in the game then
you'll have a much better time but
generally this works well enough that i
reckon you could do a really good play
through with it i really like it
the most important thing by far is that
it actually puts you in the shoes of
your character so dark souls is a tense
game but when you're actually looking
around from a first person perspective
it becomes that bit more tense for
example there's something more fun about
turning around and seeing an enemy right
in your sights with his sword raised or
when you see an arrow flying towards
your character playing with this limited
view just means that you're more
surprised by things and it makes the
action a bit more visceral i guess you
feel as though you're playing as the
character much more and i guess playing
as the character extends to all first
person games i mean this affects more
than just the combat dark souls is a
game where you really experience the
world around you and i think that
meeting npcs and experiencing the world
around you fits so well with a souls
game and i definitely wouldn't mind from
developing a first person rpg similar to
this remember that some of the first
games from maid were kingsfield games
and those were in first person imagine a
modern day king's field with souls
gameplay and that would be so good
so many people will have clicked this
video intending to figure out exactly
how i made my game in first person but
unfortunately the person who taught me
doesn't want this information available
to the public the program i'm using can
be used for many more malicious things
and i don't really want to be
responsible for the pc version
decreasing in quality at the same time i
also think some of you deserve to know
having the ability to mod the game in
this way opens up so much creative
potential it's the reason my recent
videos have such great footage i can
move the camera around i can make people
invisible i can summon other people into
my world without being white phantoms
all of this is great and there are some
of you out there who would be able to
make some really good content with these
tools however there are also people out
there who would invade other people's
worlds and mess with their games so
maybe it's for the best if i keep this
information to myself even if a big part
of me thinks that it's not a big deal if
everyone knows let me know what you
think i'm really torn on this issue
anyway i mentioned before that my recent
videos have increased in quality i was
looking at my older videos the other day
and i don't know why they got so many
views my microphone was terrible my
narration was really melodramatic and i
didn't have nearly the same amount of
skill in gathering footage
i'm speaking mostly about my first few
prepare to cry videos with the prepare
to cry series i focused on the best
stories first like artorias sigma the
sisters of chaos those were the three
most emotional stories in the game so
naturally i did them first the problem
with that is that now that my video
quality has improved the three best
stories were done when i just wasn't
really experienced so i think i'll redo
those videos i won't delete them but
i'll remake them with new footage better
narration and just better overall
quality would you guys like that let me
know
so that pretty much does it for this
video the rest of the video is just me
trying to take out the tourist demon if
you want to see how that ends feel free
to stick around
but um if you haven't subscribed already
feel free to subscribe the next few
videos i'm going to be putting out are
also mod videos showcasing two more mods
that i actually think are better than
this mod if you can believe it
so as usual guys thanks for watching and
i'll see you guys next time
you